MR. DURBIN: MADAM PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDING OFFICER: THE
MAJORITY WHIP.
MR. DURBIN: I ASK CONSENT THE
QUORUM CALL BE SUSPENDED.
THE PRESIDING OFFICER: WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
MR. DURBIN: IT HAS BEEN A GREAT
SOURCE OF DEBATE, HOW WAS
JEFFREY EPSTEIN ABLE TO TAKE HIS
OWN LIFE IN FEDERAL PRISON
AUGUST 10, 2019?
LAST WEEK WE FOUND SOME ANSWERS
IN "THE NEW YORK TIMES."
IT POINTED OUT A SERIES OF
STUNNING FAILURES WITHIN THE
BUREAU OF PRISONS.
ACCORDING TO THE TIMES, THE
NEWLY OBTAINED RECORDS OFFER NO
SUPPORT TO THE EXPLOSION OF
CONSPIRACY THEORIES THAT
MR. EPSTEIN'S DEATH WAS NOT A
SUICIDE, BUT THEY DO PAINT A
PICTURE OF INCOMPETENCE AND
SLOPPINESS BY SOMEONE WITHIN THE
BUREAU OF PRISONS.
IT WAS EVIDENT FROM THE MOMENT
HE ENTERED THE CORRECTIONS
CENTER.
ON HIS INTAKE FORM, HE WAS
DESCRIBED AS, QUOTE, A BLACK
MALE, CLOSE QUOTE, WITH NO PRIOR
RECORD OF SEX OFFENSE
CONVICTIONS.
A FIVE-SECOND GOOGLE SEARCH
WOULD TELL YOU THAT NOT ONLY WAS
JEFFREY EPSTEIN WHITE, HE WAS
ONE OF THE MOST NOTORIOUS SEX
TRAFFICKERS IN HISTORY.
ON THE NIGHT HE DIED, HE HAD
ATTEMPTED SUICIDE IN THE WEEKS
LEADING UP TO HIS DEATH, YOU
WOULD THINK THE OFFICIALS IN THE
BUREAU OF PRISONS WOULD KEEP
WATCH OVER THIS POTENTIALLY
SUICIDAL INMATE.
THE OPPOSITE HAPPENED.
HE WAS LEFT ALONE, UNMONITORED
IN HIS CELL.
THE TWO OFFICERS ON DUTY WERE
DOZENING OFF AND THE NEXT
MORNING EPSTEIN WAS FOUND DEAD.
INSPITE OF HIS DESPICABLE
CRIMES, WE WILL NOT SEE HIM
BROUGHT TO JUSTICE.
MIKE CA VAJAL WAS PICKED TO LEAD
THE PRISONS, HE WOULD HAVE HELD
THE PARTIES RESPONSIBLE
ACCOUNTABLE.
SINCE DAY ONE HE HAS SHOWN NO
INTENTION OF REFORMING THAT
INSTITUTION.
CONSIDER THE CASE OF THE WARDEN
WHO RAN THE METROPOLITAN
CORRECTIONAL CENTER THE NIGHT
EPSTEIN DIED.
HOW DID HE RESPOND TO THAT
WARDEN'S FAILURE OF LEADERSHIP?
IF YOU CAN IMAGINE IT, HE
ACTUALLY REWARDED HIM.
THE DIRECTOR APPOINTED THE SAME
WARDEN TO LEAD A DIFFERENT
FACILITY, THE LARGEST FEDERAL
PRISON IN THE UNITED STATES IN
NEW JERSEY AND IT SEEMS THAT
WARDEN HASN'T LEARNED ANY
LESSONS IN LEADERSHIP SINCE
MR. EPSTEIN'S DEATH.
LAST MONTH AN INMATE IN FORT DIX
WAS ATTACKED FROM BEHIND AND
STABBED IN THE EYE.
THESE ARE NOT ISOLATED
INCIDENTS.
FOR YEARS THE BUREAU OF PRISONS
HAS BEEN PLAGUED BY CORRUPTION,
CHRONIC MISUNDERSTANDING AND
MISCONDUCT BY HIGH-RANKING
OFFICIALS.
IN THE TWO YEARS SINCE THE
DIRECTOR TOOK CONTROL OF THE
BUREAU, HE HAS FAILED TO TAKE
CARE OF THE CRISIS IN THE
BUREAU.
A FEW WEEKS AGO THE ASSOCIATED
PRESS PUBLISHED A BREATHTAKING
INVESTIGATION INTO THE BUREAU.
THEY SAID THAT IS IT A HOTBED OF
ABUSE AND HAS TURNED A BLIND EYE
TO EMPLOYEES ACCUSED OF
MISCONDUCT.
SINCE 2019, MADAM PRESIDENT,
MORE THAN 100 FEDERAL PRISON
WORKERS HAVE BEEN ARRESTED FOR,
CHARGED WITH, OR CONVICTED OF
CRIMES INCLUDING SEXUAL ABUSE,
MURDER, AND INTRODUCING
CONTRABAND INTO PRISON.
ALL TOGETHER THESE CRIMES
ACCOUNT FOR TWO-THIRDS OF THE
CRIMINAL CASES AGAINST ALL
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE PERSONNEL,
EVEN THOUGH B.O.P. EMPLOYEES
COMPRISE LESS THAN A THIRD OF
THE WORKFORCE.
I WANT TO SHARE A FEW STORIES
FROM THE ASSOCIATED PRESS
REPORT.
AT ONE PRISON IN MISSISSIPPI,
ONE PERSON WHO -- WAS ACCUSED OF
STALKING EMPLOYEES, HE WAS
AUTHORIZED TO CONTINUE TO
INVESTIGATE ONE OF HIS ACCUSERS.
IN CALIFORNIA, A WARDEN OF A
FEDERAL PRISON -- WOMEN'S PRISON
WAS ARRESTED AND INDICTED
EARLIER THIS YEAR FOR ARRESTING
AN INMATE AND KEPT LEWD PHOTOS
OF THE VICTIM ON HIS
GOVERNMENT-ISSUED CELLPHONE AND
TOLD THE WOMAN NOT TO REPORT THE
ASSAULT BECAUSE HE WAS CLOSE
FRIENDS WITH THE OFFICIAL WHO
WOULD INVESTIGATE IT.
THE LIST GOES ON.
IT'S A RECURRING PATTERN OF
MISCONDUCT BY THOSE WHO BELIEVE
THEY CAN ABUSE INMATES AND BREAK
THE LAWS WITH IMPUNITY.
IN SOME CASES THAT'S WHAT THEY
HAVE DONE.
THE DETAILS ARE SHOCKING AND FOR
THOSE OF US WHO HAVE BEEN
FOLLOWING THE DIRECTOR'S TENURE,
THEY ARE THE LATEST DISTURBING
EXAMPLES OF FAILED LEADERSHIP.
TIME AND AGAIN HE HAS
CATEGORICALLY FAILED TO UPHOLD
HIS CHIEF RESPONSIBILITY AS
DIRECTOR.
WHAT IS THAT RESPONSIBILITY,
PROTECTING THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF INMATES AND CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS.
TODAY THE BUREAU SUFFERS FROM
CHRONIC AND SIGNIFICANT
UNDERSTAFFING.
THE DIRECTOR HAS FAILED TO
CONTAIN OUTBREAKS OF COVID-19
WHICH HAS LED TO TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF INMATES AND STAFF
CONTRACTING THE VIRUS.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE FEDERAL
PRISON SYSTEM, HE HAS FAILED.
IN 2018, CONGRESSIONAL DEMOCRATS
AND REPUBLICANS HAVE COME
TOGETHER TO ENACT THE FIRST STEP
ACT.
IT WAS AN HISTORIC PIECE OF
REFORM LEGISLATION TO CREATE NEW
PATH WAYS FOR PRISON INMATES TO
BETTER THEMSELVES WHILE THEY
SERVE THEIR TIME SO THEY CAN
RETURN TO SOCIETY ONCE RELEASED.
NEARLY THREE YEARS LATER, THE
BUREAU OF PRISONS STILL HASN'T
IMPLEMENTED MOST OF THESE
REFORMS.
UNDER THE FIRST STEP ACT
LOW-RISK INMATES ARE ELIGIBLE TO
EARN TIME, THEY CAN DO THIS BY
BEING INVOLVED IN PROGRAMS.
THE BUREAU OF PRISONS HAS NOT
APPLIED THESE EARNED TIME
CREDITS TO ANY OF THE
APPROXIMATELY 60,000 ELIGIBLE
INMATES.
NOW THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, WHICH I CHAIR, IS
CHARGED WITH OVERSEEING THE
BUREAU OF PRISONS.
WE'VE TRIED TO GET ANSWERS FROM
DIRECTOR CAVVAL AND HIS TEAM AND
ASKED FOR INFORMATION AND
DETAILS ABOUT THE INMATE BANKING
SYSTEM.
THERE'S A HECK OF A STORY.
PURPORTEDLY HAS LITTLE OVERSIGHT
BY THE BUREAU OF PRISON, HAS
ALLOWED INMATES TO AVOID PAYING
CHILD SUPPORT AND OTHER
OBLIGATIONS.
THE BUREAU REPORTEDLY ALLOWED
LARRY NASSAR, THE DOCTOR WHO
ABUSED HUNDREDS OF GYMNASTS, TO
SPEND THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS FROM
HIS BUREAU PRISON ACCOUNT ON
HIMSELF BUT PAY ONLY $300 TO THE
DEBT THAT HE OWES HIS VICTIMS.
THE BUREAU HAS YET TO RESPOND TO
OUR QUESTIONS.
IT IS PAST TIME TO REPLACE
DIRECTOR CARVAL.
LIVES ARE LITERALLY AT STAKE.
I KNOW ATTORNEY GENERAL GARLAND
UNDERSTANDS THE URGENCY.
I AM CALLING ON HIM TOLL MOVE
IMMEDIATELY TO DISMISS DIRECTOR
CARVAJAL FROM THE BUREAU OF
PRISONS.
I YIELD THE FLOOR